the long wait for wonder woman 1984
is almost over and you can feel the
excitement of the cast and crew
a virtual panel discussion for the much
anticipated sequel kicked off the dc
fandom event with a bang on august 22nd
as gal gadot chris pine kristen wiig
pedro pascal and director patty jenkins
fielded questions from fans across the
globe
including some wonderful surprise guests
jenkins and her cast reminisced fondly
about their time on set together which
must feel almost
as long ago as diana's adventures in
world war 1 after all the delays wonder
woman 1984 has seen
afterward tennis legend and wonder woman
superfan
venus williams joined in to ask a dutt
and wig which of their characters would
win in a tennis match
i think cheetah would win really
while this celebrity game of superhero
what if was nothing short of delightful
and even more special guest was waiting
in the wings
before debuting a brand new trailer for
wonder woman 1984
the fandom panel welcomed the original
on-screen wonder woman herself
the iconic former beauty queen linda
carter
despite the distance between the panel
participants emotions ran high
in the virtual hall of heroes as two
generations of amazons
expressed their appreciation for each
other carter explained that she and wig
have a mutual appreciation
which they intend to seal with a hug as
soon as they can be in the same room
and gushed with praise for jenkins and
godutz take
on diana of themyscira carter became a
tv icon during her three seasons on the
late 70s wonder woman series
and she couldn't be happier that a whole
new generation is looking up to
a whole new diana prince on the big
screen she's seen firsthand what the
character means to fans of the movies
with her own daughter falling under the
spell of good dutt's wonder woman
telling her quote i finally get what
wonder woman means to everyone
she said mom i finally get it
i finally understand why
everyone idolizes you wonder woman 1984
not only takes place in a different era
than the original flick did
but it also shows a new side of the
lasso swinging hero
this time around diana has literal
decades of experience living in the
world of man
and she uses that wisdom to her benefit
in a cover story back in june
good dutt told total film in wonder
woman 1984
she's been around she's wiser she's more
mature
she's guarded she's lost all her friends
throughout the years
but she's still doing the right thing
but she is different than when we last
saw her
in the upcoming sequel diana's beloved
steve trevor played by chris pine
is back after having presumably died a
true hero's death in the first movie
a new face is barbara ann minerva played
by kristen wiig
an archaeologist who works alongside
diana and even forms a friendship with
her
only to turn into diana's foe after a
mishap grants her the powers of a
cheetah
then there's pedro pascal's maxwell lord
a smarmy businessman with a villainous
edge who makes grandiose promises about
granting everyone's wishes
in the new trailer for wonder woman 1984
that also dropped during dc fandom
fans saw lord giving a speech from
within what appeared to be the white
house briefing
room and also spotted him having a
conversation with barbara on air force
one this has led many fans to believe
that lord perhaps
wins a presidential election using his
mysterious
wish-granting artifact to either grant
the public's wishes in exchange for
their votes
or to grant his own wish for more power
the sequel pick features a handful of
actors in yet
undisclosed roles including natasha
rothwell of saturday night live and
insecure fame
grandfather's star ravi patel and mad
men actor christopher pollaha
so there's no telling how many more
allies or antagonists diana will face in
this next adventure
in all it's looking like wonder woman
1984 will be a more than worthy
follow-up flick to the widely adored
original
catch the film on october 2nd 2020
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one